enora tacle les chroniqueurs de tpm paix
dans salut les terriens alors on va voir
l'extrait vous benjamin je vous aimais
et isabelle vous n'aimez pas été juste
l'écurie c'est vrai que juste pour
répondre et nous c'est vrai qu'on n'a
jamais autant décrypter les émissions
que là ce moment donc c'est vrai que ça
faisait longtemps peut-être qu'elle nous
a regardés benjamin vous aimez oui j'ai
essayé n'aura elle a gelé comme c'est
vrai ça pour écrire des mots rejeté
parce qu'un des leurs en kart j'avais la
cgt passant oui oui c'était pas du tout
ma meilleure amie j'ai appris à la
connaître et à découvrir et à la fin
elle a fait une boutade
aly fall dit la vérité elle dit qu'on a
une place en or qu'on est effectivement
à la télévision tous les jours et on
effectivement rémunérés pour ça que
c'est pas le bagne quoi pour moi pas à
l'usiné bref condé voilà après certains
travaillent plus que d'autres ça c'est
vrai mais bon les mots jean michel maire
je connais vraiment si c'est bien une
personne que je connais un peu aussi
sedan sur ce bateau c'est honnorat et
elle n'a pas dit ça pour points
c'est vraiment cessé même pas pour faire
le buzz à lumière une chose je vais vous
l'a dit d'ailleurs sur le plateau
voilà l année sur le plateau et elle a
raison il faut pas se vanter on n'est
pas à l'usiné on a un travail
merveilleux et ouais ce que voulait il
s'appelle vous n'aimez pas mais il
absolument pas question de ça et moi je
n'aurais n'aura tu le sais je n'attaque
pas du tout la jeune femme que j'irai
voir à l'automne au théâtre mais en
revanche c'est le message qu'on désirait
pas bougé le message que ça envoie
téléspectateurs parce que réellement des
gens en france n'ont pas être grassement
payés à ne rien [ __ ]
alors tant mieux cela vaudra c'est un
nom temps déjà grassement payés non à ne
rien [ __ ] non tant mieux si c'est ton
grave la jamaïque mais c'est pas le mien
c'était ne sais pas le cas de maxime
c'est pas le cas de christine c'est pas
le cas de gilles brassac beaucoup
résident à terminer je déteste le truc
global qui est de dire les tous
ils ne foutent rien et ils sont
grassement l'oeil et moi je voudrais pas
vrai nous a convaincu parce que là c'est
vrai que fois la série parce que voilà
opus isabelle coupey vous créé si vous
n'aimez pas du tout non pour moi j'ai
une règle dans la vie ne jamais cracher
dans la soupe travaille pas dans la
soupe
s'ils crachent dans la soupe ebit
deuxième seconde ici par les crises dans
leurs premières deuxièmement non je
pense pas je pense qu'on travaille je
pense qu'on décrit par faire moi je
passe ma journée quand même à regarder
des émissions que je connaissais pas
avant donc s'il y en a qui ont été vexés
dit la vérité filet oui j'ai été très
blessé d'autant que j'apprécie beaucoup
et nohra c'est pas bien me dire ça a
effectivement c'est cracher dans la
soupe
je trouve que c'est méchant c'est un peu
mon vieux mais je les prix comme tel
j'ai été blessé c'est le mot gelé très
mal vécu en plus c'est faux on peut
travailler sérieusement sans se prendre
au sérieux mais on bosse quand même
voilà mais regarde merci bernard si les
lyonnais l'a mis là vous là quand elle
est arrivée il est nommé s'appelle
arrêté on avait demandé des lycées s'est
mise à me laisser parler les autres
pays' alors bernard j'ai pas aimé ce cas
vous parce que je suis désolé je crois
qu'elle parle d'elle moi je travaille
ici
j'avoue y en a eu beaucoup j'avais oui
ça se verra quand
[Applaudissements]
donc ça m'a pas fait plaisir parce que
je désolé non du travail
on est heureux d'être là certes on
travaille alors les gens ne l'aiment pas
je suis étonné ben je trouve qu'elle a
fait du hainaut et j'adore et n'aura
donc elle a été généreuse
je pense que c'est plutôt les questions
de tir addition qui était un petit peu
orienté et ouais donc elle a fait le
show qui aurait tiré on va pas se mentir
il y là voilà il archive ou voici aussi
mais voilà laisser parfois dantesques de
thé chaud il fait le show comme
d'habitude mais je suis d'accord avec
benjamin on n'est pas la mine et tout
mais par contre faut arrêter de faire
croire que on est tous des feignasses
c'est aussi un métier et ça serait même
insultant pour vous si on va dire que
vous payez des gens inutilement mais ça
me fait plaisir mais je me sens bien a
jugé m oui parce qu'en fait moi je
connais mou enora malagré que vous mais
je trouve que ça correspond à son passé
ça moi aussi j'ai les poils à gratter
des brute de décoffrage et sont soit là
donc elle et elle fait pas dans la
nuance donc moi ça m'a pas ça m'a pas
spécialement choqué vous n'avez pas à
vous ouais je pense qu'au plus bas on
connaît et nora et moi pour l'aimer pour
les raisons pour lesquelles benjamin a
aimé ben moi c'est les mêmes raisons qui
ont fait que j'ai pas aimé quoi leur
dire ben c'est à dire que effectivement
hainaut a le sentiment que on est ici
autour de la table à faire un peu juste
a rigolé alors qu'elle sait très bien de
l'intérieur que on attrape il travaille
est en fait effectivement je pense que
auditions pendant un bout de quatre 4
heures de tournage du valais fini par
lui faire dire ce que bélanger entendre
la lavida vous n'aimez pas non parce que
je trouve ça un peu rédhibitoire pour
les autres et puis en plus elle se
permet de dire ça alors qu'elle n'y
travaille plus pour quoi elle ne disait
pas ça quand elle travaillait ici
voilà c'est un peu maintenant que je me
suis barré ben voilà vous êtes on était
tous payés à rien faire mais quand tu
étais là tu sais très bien la pression
que c'est sait très bien que parfois ils
ont regardé l'émission de ces très bien
qu'il faut chercher des arguments il ya
des trucs que tu sais pas par forcément
et il faut s'exprimer correctement enfin
bref rien que ça c'est quand les pieds
au delà du boulot on peut prendre
l'exemple concret de enora je pense
qu'elle l'a dit dans l'interview que
c'était caricaturé par moments et c'est
aussi qu'elle s'est pris plein de tacle
sur les réseaux sociaux et tout c'est
aussi le prix à payer quand tu es
chroniqueur mais ça fait aussi partie du
boulot
ça fait partie du boulot c'est compliqué
sur eux les gens meurtris mais je crois
pas qu'il y ait ça méchamment mais les
dirigeants voilà quelques stops en soit
effectivement elle l'avait dit oui elle
l'avait dit ici savait pas trop choquer
les personnes autour de la table on
avait plus rigoler mais vous avez ou pas
peu importe tant souffert a concerné
jusqu'à chronique et en os x ou alors
c'est là pour l'adar kabatwa